this is eight news now a volunteer group  cleaning our beaches is adding a new  member check it out meet beebot the  robot it's a solar powered robot that  tracks across the sand and picks up  trash that you may normally not see on  the surface now they tested the robot on  lake tahoe and they found that it picked  up an entire bucket of trash that was  missed by the usual cleanup crew less  volume less weight but more and more  objects and the objects we're finding  are small tiny things like micro  plastics bottle caps cigarette butts all  these things that are just out of sight  well the robot cleans as deep as four  inches underneath the surface and the  group is hoping the robot becomes a  staple to their beach cleanup crew  pretty cool stuff